when you buy an e-reader you buy into an
ecosystem as prosaic as this may sound
we prefer Amazon the newest version of
Amazon's ereader comes with access to
the company's famously extensive
bookstore plus Goodreads which lets it
recommend other books to you and you
know how earlier Kindles were slow to
turn pages and didn't quite handle
lighting well they've mostly worked that
out pages turned faster and the
paperwhite uses side lighting in the
e-ink background so you can read in any
environment although if you squint
really hard you might be able to tell
that the lighting is an entirely uniform
but that's easy enough to overlook when
you're flipping to the end of game of
thrones even faster
you